Mardi Gras celebrations already underway
in New Orleans on this Fat Tuesday which
means diet starts tomorrow it's going to
be land but for now all eyes are on a
performer who represents the heart soul
and success of that wonderful City his
name Troy Andrews better known in those
parts is Tom bones shorty and our Jamie
wax met up with the touring musician to
check out his massive Mardi Gras float
also to learn about his inspiring career
that kicked off before he could even
read
[Music]
when it comes to the sounds of New
Orleans Troy Andrews knows a tune or two
about it
[Music]
better known as Trombone Shorty he
picked up the tall instrument as a
toddler growing up in a music-filled
home among New Orleans music royalty and
the family it was one of the only
instruments that that wasn't taken up in
one of the other ones that wasn't broken
at the time he made history at just four
years old when he performed at jazz fest
then let his own brass band at the age
of six and joined Lenny Kravitz on tour
as a teen where his career really took
off
hardly anybody gets famous for playing
the trombone I mean back in the swing
era there there were a few trombone
players who led bands yeah but in your
generation that's almost unheard of yeah
well you know some people don't even
know what a trombone is everybody knows
a trumpet of sacks uh drums a piano all
of that type of stuff but being in New
Orleans the brass is King here
in the city where brass is King and
Andrews became engulfed in the Rhythm as
new orleanians tend to do when we were
11 we were playing in Jackson Square and
I remember the police coming under the
Kubota
and they say that we were playing too
loud and they they hauled us off to uh
it took us downtown to jail and then we
did like this big protests and different
things and because of that moment the
kids and people who want to play on the
street are still able to do that because
of what we did it's one of the greatest
stages in the world yeah it just happens
to be free yeah since then Andrews has
performed on some of the other greatest
stages in the world collaborating with
artists like Stevie Wonder Usher and
Dave Matthews Band but never losing
sight of the sounds of home
went out in New Orleans I wouldn't be
here and I really mean that with my
whole heart you're still chasing
something you you don't feel like you've
reached Perfection yet you've been still
reaching for something I'm still
reaching for something I'm always
practicing I'm always trying to get
better and it doesn't matter if we go
out there and playing from 5 000 people
or wherever it may be 200 people I
always play as if these people don't
know who I am
obviously that's far from the case
especially during Mardi Gras where
everyone knows Trombone Shorty after all
it's hard to miss his float I have never
stood with someone in front of a giant
sculpture of themselves for people who
are not from New Orleans what does that
mean to you uh it's an incredible honor
you know we all grew up here in New
Orleans and we watched the parades as
children but I'd never dreamed of myself
being on the float of having myself on
the float on that float Andrews LED his
very own Mardi Gras parade last week
called the crew of ferret which is
affectionately known by locals as shorty
Gras for your childhood and my childhood
most of the Mardi Gras Crews were all
white yeah yeah well you know just me
being there it created a diversity and
so we bring in different people from
different ethnic backgrounds and and we
don't see anything we just like Mardi
Gras colorful we're just showing that
this is what this city is about a big a
big gumbo let's just all do it together
Andrew's passion for inclusion inspired
him to create the Trombone Shorty
Foundation to support the next
generation of musicians I realized after
Katrina that the way that I grew up in a
musical neighborhood or no longer exist
as we know it it's not going to be there
for a while and so I wanted to be able
to reach kids City Wide that don't have
that experience that I had growing up in
tremend give them an opportunity to
learn from some of the best New Orleans
musicians so the foundation is just
about inspiring the Next Generation and
letting them know that we can through
music it could be your passport to do
whatever you want to do a Grammy award
later Trombone Shorty is a bit taller
now
and he's got even bigger dreams I mean
we are sitting here in your recording
studio could that kid who picked up that
trombone imagine this life for himself I
just knew that I wanted to play music
and from that
and here we are and there's a complete
blessing
[Music]
like old times
and guys you know it is true that New
Orleans has its issues like any large
city does but it's so beautiful on this
Mardi Gras morning to be here in the
French Quarter telling a story about
Hope and music by someone who embodies
both of those things like Troy Andrews
uh Jamie Jamie beware
there's a reveler behind you
yeah
security security
he tried to remain professional because
he wasn't sure he was not sure
crazy crazy things happen in New Orleans
guys
tell you what guys nice to meet you
wait does he know he didn't even realize
say hi to them they love
the red suits we do they have been
commenting about the suit all more okay
jarika I took you out in this this very
neighborhood and we had a good job yes
you did yes I remember that does Jamie
know how to party oh he knows how to
party oh yeah he knows how to party I I
have a set of skills with hurricanes
get one of those slushy hurricanes yeah
Take a Shot For Us yeah
great job you guys have fun down here
now I wish
I wish are we and Michelle thank you all
nighter presents yes she is Michelle
prepped for that yeah she was like I'm
gonna stay up all night she had the mic
on she was ready again thank you for
that report well